I am required by law to talk about
deflategate for at least a little while
today it was news yesterday when it came
down it was in the final half-hour the
show and all of a sudden Seaton goes
yeah there's a report their reinstating
Brady's suspension I went oh wow
alrighty I'm not sure well I guess I can
understand how Brady would react but
George Atallah works for the NFL players
association their assistant executive
director how did this go over yesterday
George when you got the news and did you
expect this news good morning Dan thanks
for having me on again you know we were
we were surprised you never want to be
on that end of a decision but I think
when you read through the dissent you
realize that we made a lot of strong
points you know it's unfortunate that
we're still talking about this issue
like you said I'm also obligated by my
job to come on and talk about this issue
because it just seems like it won't end
you know and hate to be the bearer of
bad news but it doesn't seem like it's
going to end anytime soon either here if
you know if Tom decides he wants to
continue to pursue you know any further
options so you don't like to be on this
end of a decision but the Union doesn't
look at outcomes we look at process and
if we believe that a player's rights
have been violated you know it's our
obligation to fight and we've done that
over the course of many many many years
now regardless of you know what a judge
may say have you spoken to Brady I
believed more Smith has in fact I know
he has you know again at this point
we're still trying to figure out what
the next step is do you feel that Brady
wants to take this all the way it as far
as you can no matter what I don't really
know I mean we certainly had that
feeling months ago when we were heading
into you know Rogers decision is his
second arbitration decision to uphold
his first decision you know and we took
it to court and we want on the first
round and here we are again
it up with kind of a similar dilemma so
you know I think the process now we want
to try to figure out and weigh all the
options I think we'll do that here in
the next couple of days we have 14 days
from the time of the decision to take
any or take any action or pursue any
further appeals if we want and I think
we'll probably take up most of that time
is mediation a possibility or to meet
the Commissioner halfway and take a
little bit of guilt if you're Brady is
that an option well I think the only
chance that we have at this point for a
mediation or for a settlement I think we
would need a level-headed and
influential team owner to step in and
broker some kind of deal we've always
felt that way that you know if it was
between the Commissioner making up his
mind to come up with some sort of
reasonable solution to this you know we
wouldn't get there and it's been proved
that we haven't gotten there
unfortunately that one owner who comes
to mind at this point and he had such
sway in 2011 also happened to be on the
receiving end of these penalties so
unless somebody else from that ownership
group from that management council steps
up and shows some necessary leadership
here you know again I don't really see
how that's going to happen I I apply
logic to things and call me crazy when I
do that but I go back to Robert Kraft
saying to the commissioner I'm going to
fall on the sword as an organization
we're going to give you a couple of
draft picks we're going to take a
million-dollar fine I hope that's good
enough for everybody we're willing to do
that i'll take that punishment and we
move on how would Robert Kraft as good a
businessman as he is then come back and
say I'm shocked that hey I'm willing to
do all these things and that the penalty
wasn't erased or they didn't move on
with this how is that possible George
III wish I knew I mean I wish I knew
some of the backroom dealings that take
place between you know Roger
and the owners it's not something we try
to spend a lot of time on there was
obviously a very lengthy report by
ESPN's Don Van Natta that kind of tried
to get into some of that as to how this
whole thing went down and why it went
down the way it did you know we have one
pursuit and that's protecting the
collective bargaining agreement and
protecting players rights under that
agreement so again that is our we are
zero sum about that we fight to the to
the bitter end if we have to and in
terms of League politics and that kind
of thing not really something we weigh
in on I don't leave you with this if I
gave their players association a
mulligan what would you have done
differently if anything in this Brady
case you know that is that is a great
question because when you're on this end
of a decision and you know you stand up
and kind of face the music which is
which is what you do I'm not sure we
would have done anything differently
because we did stand up for Tom we did
challenge you know Rogers discipline as
unfair we did avoid having him get
suspended last year we did expose flaws
in the process despite what people say
today even about us quote unquote giving
up something in 2011 you can't give up
something that you never had I mean
nobody would would call into your show
or you wouldn't make an argument you
know going back to your point about
logic that the league gave up 18 games
in 2011 they didn't because they never
had it so I think those are the things
that we try to look to and stand on I
mean we were principled in our fight and
and we're going to continue to protect
the CBA and once we talked to Tom you
know fortunately or unfortunately for
you and your listeners I might be back
here again do you expect to UM Brady to
start week one you know I don't know a
lot of lot of time left between now and
then but until we have some
and some leadership from the management
council from ownership who's willing to
stand up and say enough is enough let's
be done with this you know it sure seems
like the league is bent on enforcing
this penalty George great to talk to you
can't wait to talk to you again
hopefully it'll be about something other
than this but thanks for the time by
George Atallah the NFL Players
Association assistant executive director
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience